i will spend an insane amount of time
with this man on sunday eight and a half
hour edition of nfl game day morning
starts at 9 a.m eastern time his movie
is available everywhere pretty much uh
american underdog what a great beautiful
movie about his family and his career
courtesy of tivo right here the man who
has the record for most passes completed
to me
on the nfl gameday morning demo said
kurt warner how are you sir most passes
without a drop as well by the way yeah
yeah now how how about it i know i don't
know i know i know we're celebrating the
two best teams in the nfl this week and
your career
but let's talk about my catching and
believing it's been pretty good this
year i mean that's a high rise
a couple things i've seen the the
one-handed catch while you're in the
middle of leading into something yes but
as you did say we have eight and a half
hours on sunday i have to believe
there's going to be a couple more
opportunities for
catches or drops on sunday so we got we
got to try to finish the year perfect i
don't know man i know there's eight and
a half hours but did you see the promo
that they put together there's 21 human
beings on there i
i don't even know i can't even imagine
you you were three human beings shy of
running an 11 on 11 drill on the demo
that
yeah well do you see this trophy that's
sitting right look at you look at you
big time you get a chance to house the
trophy for a little while yeah we've had
it here for a couple days
what was it like for you to pick this
baby up oh my gosh i mean what was that
so many emotions um you know just
obviously winning the super bowl
to win it
in the fashion that uh that we did in
the season where i took over as the
starter and kind of that magical run i
mean it was incredible but you know when
you hold that thing
for the first time you know so many
things come back to you
uh you know about your journey and you
know where you've been and uh you know
what happened that particular season to
get you to that point because there's so
many things that happen that you go in
if that would have just been a little
differently we're probably not hoisting
this trophy and you know i think about
the two quarterbacks that are going to
be in this game i mean you voiced that
thing uh you know matthew stafford i
can't imagine all the emotions that
would go into that with the move that
was made a year ago and then the
culmination of this joe burrow i mean
you could just look back at the playoffs
with the bengals and go okay if that
didn't happen they wouldn't have won
that game and if that didn't happen they
wouldn't won that game and now here they
are with a chance to win it all so it is
uh it is a great moment uh no matter who
you are no matter how much you play
to culminate everything that you've been
through and put into uh to this game
let's take it one at a time then do you
think stafford gets a bust in that
gallery
in canton with you if he wins this game
happens kirk i'm not sure if it's as
easy as just winning this game i i think
there's more to come but
what i know is that if he was able to
duplicate some of the things he did in
detroit after winning this
um yeah i think there's there's a great
chance that he ends up in canton i think
there's still a few more questions with
him that people want to see him i i
believe so and again
you know i think there's so many
different things that go into it but
what i've loved about the playoffs is
that i believe matthew stafford's played
as well as any of these quarterbacks and
it was overshadowed by josh allen in
that first game with that unbelievable
game he had and then patrick mahomes
brings his team back from 13 in 13
seconds to win uh the game the next week
and so it kind of overshadowed but if
you look at the whole of the playoffs
matthew stafford had played some
incredible football and really the
reason that the rams are here so i think
that goes a long way uh but but i'm not
sure just that one season is enough to
kind of stamp his spot in canada that
guy has almost 50 000 passing yards
coming into that yeah i get it i get it
but you know again i think there's
there's bigger things that go into it
and winning is a big part of that so
obviously i think this would go a long
way okay then uh what
what is it about joe burrow
that uh uh now i know it is such a
clear um intangible yeah but what are
you seeing on film
that is like okay that is unicorn that
is unique that is something that is very
difficult to do what do you see well you
know it's so funny because we look at
these quarterbacks in this day and age
and we want to pull out their
superpowers and oftentimes you can see
the superpowers of these guys now that
lamar jacksons and the kyler murrays and
the the speed and elusiveness that they
have or josh allen you know the size and
his ability to run over people in the
cannon arm and patrick mahomes with all
the crazy stuff that he does and not
many people think about this up here as
a superpower the ability to see and
understand what you're seeing and make
quick decisions and get the ball to the
right guy and that is joe burrow's
superpower is that for a young guy his
ability to process information quickly
and get the ball out of his hands
is second to none and you couple that
with how he's never faced i mean you
know against the titans he gets sacked
nine times and it just i keep plugging i
don't worry about anything else around
me i just do my job and i think those
are two things that really stand out
about him and then what you know when we
want to talk about this it factor right
that's his it factor it's what's going
on mentally in his mind for a young guy
that hasn't been in the league very long
to handle everything that's kind of been
thrown at him with some of the struggles
they've had up front
uh has really been a difference maker
and you know you know for me it's fun
because he plays the game like i played
the game and so when people can't really
see that superpower they don't really
know what it is but that to me is
something that's that's special the guys
that have it are rare greatest to ever
play the game that just retired in tom
brady that's what he had he wouldn't
necessarily wow you with anything he did
physically but mentally he always
reacted well in the biggest moments and
it seems to be that
is what joe burrow does kurt warner here
on the rich eisen show so um you just
said
something that that that stuck at me you
referred to tom brady as the guy who
just retired did he
yeah he did you did he yes he did i saw
it on instagram then i saw it on twitter
and i read about it
and i heard about it and then i heard
him this past monday are you talking
about ever since said never say never
but why you never know right i mean
nobody wants to you know be the guy that
says i'll never come back and then some
crazy situation happens and yeah but the
crazy situation could be the pretext is
saying i said never but you know
something like this i mean it could be
coming but i
like he didn't think he was playing in
the super bowl he didn't think he was
going to play again he thought he was
done and that's true you know and so i
don't know maybe tom just doesn't want
to be wrong so i say you know never say
never but
he's got to be done i mean you can't
make a comeback
i don't know i mean he probably could
ask me sir one of the many reasons and
there's many uh that your story is so
unique and is in theaters near you
there's a guy named brett favre who
played
and um i spent many a night at nfl
network in the early years waiting for
him to make a decision not going home
because he made a decision that went
against the decision that he made then
they moved on to another guy and he said
now wait a minute i'd like to backtrack
on my decision for the next number of
times he's in the hall of fame with you
no so no doubt you think you think
brady's done i do believe he's done so
then why would he say what he's saying i
mean again i i think you just you leave
everything open and maybe it's just fun
to be able to have people like us
continue to talk about him even when
he's done but i mean i think there's two
things to me is that the work that tom
puts in
to get ready for a season yes i mean
that's not something that you just kind
of fall into like oh you know i'll come
back for training camp and and go play
again
he wants to put in that work to be great
and then i think the second thing is
oftentimes why people come back is they
miss it but they don't really have
anything else that they're
they've got to do and so they find
themselves in the fall going oh my gosh
what am i going to do with my life i
don't think tom has that issue whether
it's family stuff that he's doing or all
the different business endeavors that
he's going to take on and i think he's
going to have something that is going to
feed that competitive nature
inside of him maybe not like those three
hours on sunday afternoon but he's got
plenty of stuff that will fill that void
and so for those two reasons i just
i don't see it it took him three
business days though
i mean he said
he tweeted he tweeted and instagramed it
out on a tuesday and then monday
jim gray on his own podcast asked him
you know are you definitely retired and
then he gave this very well thought out
and reasoned response that
kind of caught me off it's still fresh
it's still fresh you know how long did
it take for you to finally say i'm done
i'm done
i mean i knew when i retired but i had
also been thinking about it the year
before so we went to the super bowl the
year before right and i was
contemplating it as we were making that
run and you know just some of the things
that go into it i was like
this may be it for me and you know so
once the super bowl was over and it kind
of got away
i was kind of waiting to see if that
itch came back and like that fire came
back and it was a couple weeks and i'm
like all right i still want to play
again about halfway through the next
year um that feeling came back like
this is it you know the work that goes
into it the commitment that you have to
make uh the toll that it was taken on me
physically it was just kind of like
it's time so i knew halfway through the
year i was going to retire
and so i had a half of a year to for it
to sink in and going through the
playoffs and talking to the people that
were close to me and so
i knew pretty definitively at that point
in time
i was done because it had you know
carried on for about a year and a half
of of me contemplating it i've never
asked you this question so i'm gonna do
it anyway um
so if ben's pass was a little
underthrown or went off the fingertips
of san antonio homes or he dotted the
the out of bounds park would you have
retired
i don't know that's a great question um
i never really thought of it that way
either you know for me it was just the
feel of do i want to come back or do i
not want to come back
um
but i don't know i mean you know because
i'm sure that
you know maybe that overrides even the
feeling you have like okay i feel like i
should play another year but man if i
play another year like there's no way
i'm gonna finish it like this um but i
don't know it never crossed my mind
because i never really
you know considered uh retiring until i
got away from things and reflected on
what i was feeling but if you had that
magic carpet ride send off you know yeah
maybe that's what brady's sitting around
thinking right that could be my last nap
was handing it off to leonard fournette
yeah like i i didn't get to touch the
football i mean a great example for you
and that was dick vermeel after our win
in in 99 yeah he retired you know
because he's like oh my gosh you know
went from here to there now i won my
championship and and everything feels
great and he retires and you know a year
later he's back coaching the kansas city
chiefs he's like what was i doing you
know like the emotions of that moment
led him to retire as opposed to you know
maybe just a feeling like i was done so
i don't know maybe maybe you've got
something there now you this storyline
that you can keep going for a while all
right let's keep we could do that good
thing vermeel didn't have a podcast to
come on the air and say you know i'm
done or i think i'm done or anything
like that
okay uh tivo uh tivo spring 4k what do
you uh stream 4k bringing all your
streaming content and favorite live and
streaming shows movies and sports
together in one place yeah it's awesome
um you know so my wife is the streamer
in my family sues or you or you guys
both stream we're on peacock sir so oh
okay all right yeah don't stream
anything else no i mean all right okay
i'm saying yes while being
self-promotion okay all right yeah we uh
we stream everything specific
specifically my wife and so she's got a
million things especially during the
season like oh you got to watch this
show and you got to watch that movie and
so
i'll try to you know carve out a little
time for her and inevitably yeah she's
trying to find her show she's like oh i
don't know what streaming network it's
on it's on this one it's on that one and
she's navigating around and i'm getting
bored like i gotta go i gotta go do my
work i gotta go watch film so the tivo
stream 4k is one device plug it into
your tv brings all your streaming
services together on one screen you just
type in the search whatever show you
want to watch like if you're into sports
movies you want to type in american
underdog boom it's going to pull it up
from whatever streaming service you
don't have to worry about it's easy to
use yes if you're a sports you know fan
it will read your history as all smart
devices do and so it'll pop american
underdog up there if you haven't seen it
yet i don't know why you wouldn't have
seen it but if you haven't seen it yet
pops it up there because that is one of
your favorites and so everything in one
house you don't have to worry about
looking around all the streaming
services because it just pulls it
from whichever one your favorite show is
on and so we're kicking things off on
saturday super bowl weekend with a
little live
cooking show as well as a watch party
for american underdog so if you want to
find out more about that you can go to
blog.tivo.com if you want to buy the uh
tivo 4k stream 4k you can go to tivo.com
or amazon and boom i just made your life
easier no you did i did you did and then
i i'm i'm
i'm i feel like i'm i don't know
i feel like i'm gonna take a little
credit for something here okay
you being
um self-promotional a little bit right
there while also being promotional
did have i kind of shown you the way i
went up front a little bit between
between you and one end of the desk yes
and herb
on the other end of the desk i mean i am
sandwiched between self-promotion
for four hours eight and a half hours on
sunday yes and so it just starts to rub
off a little bit i just realized wait a
minute so i have two eyes in my name
irv has three
mariucci has two
and you're just the guy nothing you're
the team you're the team you're the team
you're the team i got a w and an e i got
a wii i got a wii
there we go
i agree that's very very well done who
wins the game kurt what do you got for
me well you know we
we can't tell the people i know it's
your show but we have eight and a half
hours to talk about who's going to win
this game that's what rams it's a ramsay
you're it's it's who's house it's ram's
house because you do that you're very
good at that too you're like well i
gotta go with this and you you spend
eight hours breaking down film and
giving everybody the possibilities
because
you know it's just possibilities right
you you i think you take it as a
personal front being asked to choose one
team over another there are so many
variables
until i get a chance to break down in
front of everybody all the different
things that i see uh and then i will
give a prediction when it's all said and
done mm-hmm um you know that last
whatever hour of our show before i head
over to the stadium to call the game i
was that's right you're calling the duh
yeah yeah wes woodward you get to call
the game as well so how many super bowls
is this you calling this is my fourth
yeah you and kevin kevin harland
westwood so i'm uh i'm pumped i think
it's gonna be a great game and i just
i'm one of those guys that i played in a
super bowl where i didn't feel our team
played our best football and there's
nothing worse than walking away and
going in this moment we didn't play our
best win or lose not as important as do
you play your best football so that's my
hope is that we get a great football
game both of these quarterbacks
play great football everybody walks off
the field going you know what we left it
all out there and the best team won and
uh i'll tell you who i think the best
team is so okay so which
which was the one that you didn't play
your best football on which one oh the
second one against you know i mean new
england and we were i mean 14 point
favorites and that's the other beautiful
thing right is that rams are going to be
the favorites going into this game the
underdog yeah uh you know bengals going
into this game but i've been in a game
where i've been the underdog and i've
been the favorite
and you know that's what it's all about
is that that's why we play those three
hours that you play ten times maybe one
team wins nine out of ten but doesn't
matter what happens one time well since
you brought this up i don't know if you
just before i let you go have you seen
the tuck rule documentary the 30 for 30
the nfl the films documentary yeah
obviously no it just came out just oh no
so i've seen something else it's with
brady and
uh uh charles woodson who's on
tomorrow's show it's brady and charles
sitting down and watching the play oh
okay together okay they've never talked
about it with each other before
and they break it down it's a whole 60
minutes on it and the number of things
that happened in the game leading up to
it and then after it
as well
that could have knocked brady and the
patriots out and maybe it i don't know
you might have been taking on the
raiders that that year as well yeah no
no doubt obviously so much it could have
gone into all of this and that's the one
thing that you realize you know when we
talk and we do all of our stuff on our
show and you know you let us know who
you picked at the beginning of the year
and if they're in the super bowl like
you knew something special which he
didn't know anything special he just got
lucky
but that becomes the point right is that
everybody that gets to this point yeah
there's things that play in their favor
that you don't think about there's
moments in different games that you go
man if that would have just been a
little bit differently
you know we might not be sitting in this
moment and every team can do that in
every single game and it's the beauty of
our sport it's it's overcoming those
moments it's you know it's the tart drop
of the interception did that change
everything did the chiefs play at the
end of the first half where they didn't
get three points did that put the bing i
mean so there's so many different
moments like that that teams will look
back and go that was the moment that we
knew we had a chance to win this thing
i think i i i think that
that chiefs play at the end of the half
and everything else that's at the bottom
of that uh second half might be
something that
you know they'll be thinking about for
years to get no doubt curt you're the
man i will see you on sunday eight and a
half hours when kurt will eventually say
i'm a ram of course i'm going to take
that
see brockton laughs he knows he knows
like a close game kurt like a lot of
points like what do you think on sunday
i know you're going to be watching this
for eight and a half hours so well for
sure but i'm trying to get information
but he would have to hurt you and kurt
is not a man who would hurt you like 27
20 would never hurt anything like that
i think it might be a little bit a
little bit wider than that oh
ram's blowout says kurt warner
don't put words in my mouth right you
can't do that on your show it says
correct you gotta wait for me to say it
okay whoa i'm sorry jeez oh it's my show
thanks for coming on it it's your social
you can give my predictions yes kurt
warner says yeah that works you have
your show and we'll see how it works
blog.tivo.com uh for everything that you
uh need to stream everything in one spot
on a tivo device you got to do it good
to see you sir you too man hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here